okay great so now we're gonna have the
second talk of the morning
uh by intent okay please go ahead thanks
intent
yeah so this is genre for free ltd
and santosh and a very accurate picture
of me
uh so this talk i only have 20 slides so
i should have enough time to answer any
people question
so please feel free to ask me otherwise
the thought will be too short
so this topic is again about this form i
have been working on this problem for a
while
you have a commerce set different any
points you can tell whether the point is
in the center line is the membership
oracle
and we want to sample a part according
to uniform distribution inside the k
this problem is well study in this talk
i try to
show a picture of everyone the first
time i saw his name so there is many
picture here
as you can see the running time is
gradually improving
but one thing to be careful is the last
results
need to assume certain thing about the
commoner set it does not
apply to general congrats set so for
general common sense the previous best
we said is
end to the fall and it is 2003
uh i will divide what is well until
later we will use this result
but for this special case we can get n
coupe
and in general there is some belief
at least centos believe that i am lost
here if i believe
centers believe for the general case and
could be is the best
or this is the number of we are
measuring the
time by the number of oracle the total
random income is higher because
it's step you need to do something more
so in this term our research is this we
for any commerce set
we can sample in n to 3.5 time
and if we assume chaos conjecture is n
coupe
uh just to be mark here
say let's say we have i will divide our
scales conjecture
but if we assume case conjecture in fact
almost
i'm not sure about those running time
but for this two running time
if under chaos the running time is still
m4 and
m3 so this this
this one is kind of special
we'll explain why kls does not improve
for the general case before
we have the same running time if we care
about
instead of sample points we want to
compare the volume
for example if we want to get a one
percent epsilon
a multiplicative approximation to the
volume
then the running time is 3.5
over epsilon squared
uh epsilon square is necessary to ask
for estimating
volume uh so this is the result
uh i'm ignoring some long term here
there is some point later
yeah during the whole time i ignore all
the point lock terms
uh so before talking about our research
we need to
cover some basics uh
quick and there's a
lower bound of any sort uh
i i think centos proof ends great or bad
before yeah i am not super sure
yeah so lower band is a very cool
question if anyone can do
uh so in some sense this result if
santa's belief is true
if income is the best and this result is
the best if chaos is true
so finally i can forget about this
problem i should just focus on kls
uh yeah so
this few slides i have used too many
times but i will use that because it's
covering the basics
so almost all the result in the previous
slides
based on this algo called
bulwark so the algorithm is like this
let's say you are starting at
some point inside the set then you
sample a point inside a ball
of radius delta uh
if you sample a point inside and you go
to there
otherwise you you forget about that
point and sample again
so this is the block uh
this work is well defined for any set
even if it's long commas but the core
problem is if you apply this for long
conversation
it can take forever to go from one to
another
one if the sets have some bottom neck
here then it take forever to
go to another part so it mainly work for
a comma set
and and to measure the the performance
of bulwark we need a constant call
trigger constant so for any set k
we divide the trigger constant phi k by
this
you search over you have a set you
search
over all subset of k s
and you compute the uh ratio between the
a intersection the this area
over the volume of the smaller side
and you search off you find the minimum
one and this is the trigger constant
for example for a sphere the trigger
constant will be large because
you you can finish it constantly it's
measuring how difficult it is to cut the
set
into two and for sphere is difficult to
cut into too easy to cut a lot of stuff
here
but for satellites then the surface area
here is small compared to the area
compared to the volume
so the general statement about
mixing time of forward is like this the
running time is
n over five squared and
delta square so if the set is
if the trigger constant is larger if it
is harder to cut the set
the ball makes faster and if the step
size is larger it also makes faster
here i measure the number of steps
number of successful steps
that mental step you successfully go to
the new pond
and if you pick your step size too large
then you left
then you need to sample a lot of time
in order to do one step so you don't
want to pick too large step size
so is epsilon the statistical distance
to uniform what is upside down uh this
is the tv distance between your
distribution and
and the target distribution use it for
uh
yeah uh one thing to be careful is the
chicken constant is not a fine
variant it can be arbitrary small even
for conversation
for example if the session look like
this then you can
you can cut the set in the middle the
surface area here is
one the volume here is l so the chicken
constant is one over l
uh so we need to normalize the set a
little bit
and as you will see turns out
in terms of algo the most difficult part
is to normalize the set
uh so we will
normalize the sensor set the correlation
matrix is identity
uh and we call our set is isotropic
effects missile
and the covariance is identity uh notice
that uh
people in mathematics usually define
isotropic differently so this is a
slightly different definition
they usually have a slicing constant
here
somewhere
uh so
one thing to notice is uh if the
conversation is isotropic you can prove
as long as delta is less than one foot
and
the ball will success with constant
probability after step
and wonderful end is tight for hypercube
imagine if you are in hypercube
you randomly sample a pond then
then there is many coordinators close to
the boundary because the independent
sample some coordinate will close to
zero or one
and because of this if your step size is
too large you're going to step outside
and that's why step size will scale
with n if if the dimension is larger you
need
small step size and if you play in this
step size wonderful
end to the previous film then you will
get this running time
uh uh to sample a part inside as a
tropical asset
you take n square over five square step
so if the set is already isotropic
then the only thing we need to study is
the isotropic cons
is the chicken constant of the set
uh but turns out uh in terms of algal
the most difficult thing is to make a
set isotropic
uh so canon watch and see now which
uh make this conjecture for any
isotropic camera set
the trigger constant is at least a
universal constant
so if we put it pre in the previous
results then
for isotropical asset we can sample in n
square step
uh placenta somehow we live for certain
conversation it should be n cube
ah yeah so for this conjecture
well why not n squared uh
because okay the roughly this
is just a belief it doesn't really have
any reason the roughly belief is this
uh in order to make the imagine
yeah imagine the original imagine
obviously the set look like this
is very and what you want to do is make
it isotropic
and to do this you need to estimate the
covariance matrix of a body
and to estimate a
covariant matrix of a body is known in
the end
sample and sample you not do to estimate
the query matrix
and so you so in order to make something
isotropically and sample
and each sample you should take n square
step
that's why santa's belief is anchored
yeah but this is just a belief maybe
someday someone probably a totally wrong
it will be more interesting but
is there a lower bound here for this
uh i've i think santos proof
uh volume and squalor urban i'm lost to
her for seven but that's for isotropic
i don't think it employs uh like so
suppose you know that the best thing you
can do that the tropic position is n
squared
still does it imply that the best you
can do is uncubed in general
why uh oh you are asking
oh oh oh you are asking if someone saw
in the isotropic k is n squared can we
get n cube
uh okay
uh we know kls
implies the n cube i am lost if
isotropic n squared
implies kls is correct uh
yeah i don't know my my firm need
kls instead of n square isotropic
oh yeah uh for the keras conjecture is
more wealth study than sampling
there is uh the first launch review we
saw is
one over one and uh people study
one difficulty of chaos is at least
originally you may thought
one difficulty of chaos is if because
you need to search over offset
what about if you only search oversphere
turns out that quantity is measuring how
close is the body with
a sphere with some other quantity and
so there's many results on here and then
i'll dance so a very amazing resultant
so that two quantity is
excessively the same and then we change
we a few years ago santos and me change
one sentence in that proof and get
an improved bond uh so
this is currently the best uh
yeah i would really love someone improve
this bond that i don't need to
think about this anymore uh but
but using this we get n to 2.5
with with guess this is n squared
so now i will go over how we get
this result uh the rest of the taurus
is mainly talking about how we come up
with the algo
the proof is almost true through just
the
algorithm is the interesting part
so in order to explain our algorithm
first explain how people do this
previously
so there is many previous algo to make
our body isotropic
our elbow based on the paper by lowest
and
vampire so the algorithm
you first start with a ball inside the
set
uh one thing to uh mention is we always
assume our corner set contains a
tiny ball and is is contained inside a
large ball
i think this is necessary at least the
internal boy is necessary
the reason is imagine you
i give you a call asset but you don't
tell me any ball inside
then basically what happens is you can
keep asking the
membership oracle and the membership
article can keep telling you no
because it's somewhere you don't know
where is it so the internal ball is
important that's why we can start with a
ball
inside the k
so the elvis this will start with a ball
let's say with radius t
we will first we will keep enlarging the
ball until the ball covers the whole set
each step resample and pawns inside the
the k-intercept bar
initially the ball is inside the set so
k-intercept for
is just a ball we know how to sample
endpoints inside ball
so by some result by seriously
visioning the proof is take only n
sample to estimate the variance this is
why we need an example
and and what we do is after we
estimate the coercion matrix we
transform the whole body
such that k intercept b is isotropic
and then and then we enlarge the ball
yeah there is one step left
you enlarge the ball by two
so this is the algo and the key thing we
are using
is if k intercept b is isotopic
then k intercept 2b is well wanted
namely uh the
the the the long square
the average lump square is n and
and the body the covariance of of the
body is at least some identity
you can think this condition is is kind
of
roughly same as you have a ball inside
it's not exactly the same but
this implies this result and because
we're just enlarging the ball certainly
there is a ball inside but turns out you
can prove something strong
and oh yeah in fact i have that sentence
uh uh yeah and then
another factory you they use is we can
sample around the body in
n group time so what is the total
runtime of the algo
uh notice every time we enlarge the body
by factor of twos who used to expect a
lot money step
more precisely is not not m but lot of
something
uh and you step with n samples so you
have
n here and your sample is sampling from
a well on the body
because after you enlarge we know like
step is around the body
so it's anchor p that's why the total
one time is
m4
and one thing to notice is this one
income is the best known
even assuming kls so
yeah when i went to some
common geometry conference sometimes
people ask me that krs has any
implications on sampling
and unfortunately for for sampling
general conversation previously we don't
know any
and so one good thing about this paper
is showing
chaos is indeed related to the capacity
of sampling
so this research is roughly at 2006.
so at that paper they they put this
paragraph in the paper this is just a
funny thing these two pictures sent us a
little wash at 2006 you can notice
centers is slightly different
yeah so they say in their paper they
believe there is one extra improvement
in the paper
if the chaos conjecture is true we just
need a little algorithm of making body
isotropic
and at that time they don't know what is
the algo and turns out the algorithm is
something simple enough they should have
noticed at that time uh yeah
uh
but one thing to notice is this paper
is showing in order to in order to make
something as your topic
it suffice to study the cases where i
wanted
because this this every step you just
need to sample from a well-rounded
body you just need to make this
well-rounded body isotropic
so from now on i will assume the body is
already well wanted
recall where wanted mean the the trace
of covariance is
n and the covariance is
at least identity
uh so the algorithm
is something like this
uh yeah let's say we have a well-rounded
body
uh notice for a well-rounded body you
could still have some eigenvalue as
large as would n
remember y is well under well under is
trace of covariance
so expectation of x squared
oh i am kind of assuming the body is
center
the the center of gravity is zero so
the chase of covariance is n and the co
log n o n and the covariance
is at least a constant so you could
still have some directing that is very
large
and that is the reason why sampling is
low on this form
if you have some direction very large
thing if you doing a random walk here
then you take forever on those large
diversity
and so our idea is very simple because
the algorithm is low because mainly
because of those large direction
so what we do is just try to remove
those large digesting
uh so the algo is this uh how to
how to remove let me let me remove those
frames here uh
so our elbow will maintain a ball
inside a body the ball starts with
radius
one we know covariance larger than
identity implies the
universe inside the body b
c o r is inside
we will maintain this invariant during
the whole algo
so each step we will sample r squared
many sample
uh gradually we will enlarge the ball
inside
so initially we will only sample a fuel
sample and
at the end we'll sample and many samples
so after we compute this we use this to
compute the empirical covariance matrix
notice this empirical correlation matrix
has
it's really doesn't look like the
correlation matrix in particular
this is lawful rank this matrix uh
so for those small dimensions you should
expect this has nothing to do with the
two covariance uh
but what we care about is the large
dimension on the
empirical coercion matrix we look at all
eigenvalues larger than
n and what we do is
we look at the space perpendicular
so in terms of picture the v is here
then we look at the perpendicular space
v transfer
oh yeah and then what we do is we
enlarge the body k
on that direction so you get a new body
the blue one sorry question
yeah where are these r square samples
taken from
you mean why n square no no no where are
they being taken from
this is from uh from k from k
yeah okay
and are they generated by uh
like for each sample you you start a new
random walk
yeah yeah just do a ball walk okay so
they're independent
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh where is this b of uh
you said you're going to maintain this
invariant that oh
0 r right oh i'm saying i will maintain
i will prove later each step there is a
ball inside the body where for this out
initially this is true by the definition
of well-rounded
and because we are scaling up the small
dimension we'll maintain that
okay yeah and your step will increase
the hour roughly by two
uh so roughly speaking the intuition is
this
uh in some sense our algorithm is scale
up all the eigenvalue less than
n we look at the space perpendicular to
n
and then scale that up and so eventually
you should expect our eigenvalue will
converge to n
ish and initially k is far from
isotropic
but initially we only feel sample
and at the end when k is isotropic
is easy to sample those set and we need
more sample
so what will happens is at the end every
step will take
same amount of time so in some sense we
are balancing between
how difficult to sample and how many
samples we live
so what we will prove is during the
whole algo
covariance is less than n
uh this is kind of true as long as i
prove to you the empirical coercion
matrix is
an accurate estimation for those
eigenvalue larger than
uh another thing is uh again this l will
take roughly log many steps
let's say series m oh oh for this
version is log n because we know the
eigenvalue bounded by n yeah this word
thing is
exactly log n uh
and in some sense the main thing we need
to proof is two things
one is the empirical covariance matrix
is equity enough to estimate those large
eigenvalues
and also we will maintain this
invariance
there is above with this out inside k
certainly we also need to find the
capacity of this algo
also for the accuracy of empirical
covariance
is just follows by matrix chain of bond
yeah it is done by matrix and china
someone else
uh yeah but we say something like this
uh roughly speaking you can
ask if you only have k sample you can
add
the empirical coercion matrix is uh one
plus
epsilon approximately to a but with an
additive term
the additive term is roughly change a
over k
this is just a standard application of
machine channel
so i'm not showing here uh
but notice for example if you put
k is n and if we know a
if we know the original body is isotopic
then chase
a is n in that case then you get this is
a small term
but for our case we only have k sample
what what we will show is
turns out throughout the whole algorithm
trace a
is less than r squared n
and if this is true then you can just
put it into this formula
chase a is r square n
and you have k is k
is uh what uh case r squared in the last
slice
and we only care about the case epsilon
is constant
so you see the empirical covariance
is a constant approximation of a with
additive term
n so you can detect all the arguments
larger than n
uh so this is a quiz how to prove this
annual c
i have enough time to wait for 10
minutes
anyway we see it's just this
uh remember each step we scale up some
dimension by roughly factor of two
um so each step
oh i guess i should uh let me go back to
the last slice in case you forget
is that we scale up some dimension by
fact of two
and we scale up out by factor of 2 ish
so so each step change a
remember this is covariance when you
scale up the body by 2 is scaled by 4
and r scale by two and you end the alpha
formula and r squared less than
and yeah so chase yeah i guess just that
two
implies trace a
oh and initially chase a is m by
the way under condition so you have this
yeah so there is nothing to prove here
uh
yeah so you see the the real thing to
proof is just
this uh
uh during the whole algae there is a
ball
inside the k maybe i should explain why
we care about this
uh turtle uh
if you have a body
uh if you have a body such that you
have a ball of radius out inside the
body
then what happens is you can take the
step size for the ball walk is
out overboard and
so if there is a larger ball inside body
we can take a larger step
and through the boardwalk makes faster
and that's why we want large body
large ball inside and this one is kind
of
like improved by picture let me see uh
sorry inside what was lambda again uh
uh let me see uh
i didn't define lambda before lambda is
the mass eigenvalue of the body
of the covariant matrix lambda is
slam the mess so for our case you should
think lambda is
n
i already use say you should initially
the mass eigenvalue is n and because we
left the scale those side
measuring is always n-ish
and let me see
remember what happened to the algo we
scale up all dimension with
the variance less than lambda you can
think this
you should just yeah i should just put n
here
and
and so so this direction is we this is
repub
so by the definition we know this
dimension the covariance
on that dimension is larger than n
i mean restrict to restrict to the
dimension v
so what happens is uh by some standard
result there is a ball
on that subspace of size lambda
and how about other dimension uh by by
the
by the induction last step we already
proved there is a body of size
out in the dimension we probe
and because we scale up that dimension
by 2 so now this step
we have a ball of size 2 out here
so so now now it's just a geometric
question if
i have a body command set this dimension
we have uh
we have a ball of size with lambda and
this direction we have a
ball of size 2r then what is the largest
ball inside
yeah by some calculation i don't want to
yeah by some calculation you can prove
there is a ball of
2 hours inside
yeah it's just some explicit calculation
and this this is where there's some
uh yeah
i forget why there is some law end
coming up
uh this i think this
law ends come from our choice of lambda
instead of the film
uh yeah but
anyway you can see this this film is
just some simple geometry
consideration
so now we we have every component
so now we go back to the remember
what is the result for
bulwark in general the running time of
bulk
is n squared the max eigenvalue
over
the step size squared
this this is known even without kls
and now now what we know about wait i
think it's just
n here uh let me see
uh n
square yeah i think it's
n okay it's n lambda over delta squared
and we know delta is uh r for
n and then we know lambda is
n so you get n cube over r
squared
and so each step because there is a ball
of size r
inside and because the covariance has
the n we know each step take
n cube over r square oh this one is
assuming k
s sorry this is assuming careless
uh yeah so and because each step we
leave our square samples so this cancel
with that term
and so under krs each phase is n group
and this is why the whole algorithm is
encode
but anyway the the intuition of the
algorithm is pretty simple
is just saying we don't really let n
sample to asymmetrical areas
because for one thing kind of we only
care about the large dimension first
so if you first estimate those then you
get better one time
uh yeah this is why i believe they
should have floated step before
so without kls then turns out we need
isotropic constant for
for largest isotropic body and
and turns out for a long isotropic body
we have the krx constant look like this
uh it depends on the food islam of the
coercion matrix
and if you apply this film instead of
kls
it gives a capacity of n 3.5
and and if somehow someone
improved the kls constant from beta
equals to
one-fourth to someone something else
in terms of you can prove as long as you
prove
as long as you have an estimate of
isotropic
convex body then you have a good
estimate for any common set
again by something look like for
baseline but you say is uh
some p long and using this
this result uh it will impress the
capacity of
of of sampling is
slightly less than 3.5
so this is saying as long as there is
any
improvement on chaos we have improvement
on sampling
yeah so this is everything i will only
have one slice left
any other question
yeah but yeah i i yeah i still amaze
this how simple is this l
go oh visually i plan to make sure this
favorite is less than 10 pages that i
finally have one storefront paper less
than 10 page
but unfortunately michael offer add more
stuff inside
there is how do we sell inside
yeah but yeah i yeah i would
really love to see if someone improved
the chaos there is so many experts in
this
this workshop here let me give you yet
and multiplacing of
chaos less than one-fourth
yeah there's obviously there's so many
uh motivation for example care
improvement chaos implies improving
slicing which
is open for many decades but but
but but i want to argue why 1 4 is
kind of special so
my real motivation is just so a picture
of my student
how tan uh so so
many of you probably know this results
uh central limit firm for common set
the firm say this you have the cause
body
and you randomly will randomly find the
direction x
and then you take the marginal on that
dimension
and the central room so this is close to
uh
close to uh normal distribution
uh yeah the current estimate is very
precise i forget what is that
uh but we don't know the touch uh bond
for this yet
so my student how can centers and me
make a conjecture how about can you
prove a general essentially
from instead of sampling a
part according to a sphere
you sample according to an ella concave
distribution
uh yeah and we still can't touch it the
marginal
is close to some normal distribution
uh there is a equilibrium form of this i
like more because it's more symmetric
using different any two isotropic
no concave isotropic log of k
distribution
you take two uh random sample p from
distribution p a random sample q from q
and you take the inner product uh
the conjunction is saying this this
distribution is close to
normal distribution uh
uh because i noticed we did
this version is grow and here because
the lifebound
of the bluetooth distance between the
llama with with
with standard duration with n is would n
so we conjecture is better than a
lifebound
and what we can show is uh we can show
you
uh if someone improve the kls
beyond one over four then
then this central limit film is called
in fact if someone proved something like
this uh instead of one five
you just improve the bond by i forget
what n or
n you just improve by a lot and better
than that
implies this this this field
so at least this is a funny statement
that that
is useful only after you improve the one
fourth
yeah but obviously we don't know how to
do
yeah uh yeah in the last few years i've
been trying to improve from forth
and end up by only getting a lot of film
there is
kind of equivalent to improving one for
off
there is a longest this is the lightest
one
yeah so we hope we realize someone can
prove that
yeah thank you
you think since that um anyone have any
questions for intent
um do you know in this generalized
conjecture do you know
to prove that this
p times q is is close to some say any
even distribution
and some any non-level bounds that it's
not just exposed to gaussian
close to something even i
i never thought about this question uh
[Music]
i i worry that would i
oh i should mention generalized clt also
in pisces back to
improve chaos and i worry your evenness
will also you
myself think so i think even this is not
trivial
yeah yeah exactly
yeah this was my impression just to get
it even it's already the problem yeah
yeah exactly
i have a question hey hi
uh so basically like
the general framework here has nothing
to do with
convex bodies it just says that if you
have a distribution such that it's
easier to sample
when it becomes more isotropic yeah then
there's a framework to make it isotropic
and then you know for convex bodies you
need this exact
dependence on how close to isotropic it
is
so i'm just wondering if like it's very
likely that this
framework has more applications so i
guess the first thing
to ask is maybe for polytopes
for example for you you can say
something new
yeah two weeks later i will give you
some package
yeah yeah two weeks later i'm giving it
on sampling on python
so so is is it also the case that you
improve like the polytope case because
it's easier to sample from polytopes as
they become more isotropic
the the reality is forward is horrible
for
sampling for because of some
computational
issue i will i will discuss that in
that talk okay yeah sorry
what is horrible uh power
a ball walk yeah yeah
and then and then there's all your
papers
with the like new stuff
but i i'm not sure how much they depend
on isotropicity
algorithms i find your marriage ah
i see i see ah so the best known
algorithm is a
fine and variant yeah i tell you ah
i understand okay and
my second question is there is
are these a could these ideas be helpful
if you just want to do pca
like you just want you know the top
k eigenvalues slash eigenvectors
could this be helpful somehow of a
concert
yeah yeah the pro yeah that my eyes
is better is the best known i i don't
know any result on this direction so
i am not sure yeah it's not it's not
like if you want the eigenvalue together
with the
eigenvector for the top ones it's not
clear to me
you know if these ideas are helpful uh
yeah i yeah i don't know uh
but probably if you just want the agent
value then
like this strategy seems to help because
but
if you just want to talk about maybe you
just found a random direction
and automatize over that i think
yeah that's probably better i mean
that's that that's probably better if
you want a very small number of
top eigen values yeah and probably you
know like
if you want like the root and top ones
then it seems likely that
you know this framework helps oh yeah
but maybe
it is it could have no if you just want
more
even if you want more then you can offer
ghana to that direction
and automize again maybe this is a new
sampling algo
yeah i see anyway yeah i don't know
okay then
um any any further questions actually i
i have a question
just as someone who's not i guess in
this area but i'm curious i mean just
from what you've written
you have this conjecture of the root n
right at the bottom of the slide
but in principle beta could be
arbitrarily small right beta could be
zero
so does that does that mean that uh yeah
that that will implies
yeah your faith is zero i only get
enthused
i i may be getting i don't know point
either probably not
and a small one i will get
and two smaller one here at least
i see but i mean i guess my question is
why so why do you specifically
conjecture their root n
as at the bottom as opposed to because
if beta is zero then that's going to be
even much better right
oh because here this body have that
this distribution i have have this same
word and
this is a normal distribution before n
here
a normal distribution with variance and
so this distribution have have diameter
is
effectively what n so the this
the derivative distance of this normal
distribution with a delta 0 here
is n
so we
i'm confused with that when you compare
with the theorem that you have
highlighted in orange where you say
that the distance is o of n to the two
beta so i mean
principle beta could be smaller than a
quarter right oh
oh you're asking why is that just
conjecture this as
one yeah yeah something root n is the
trivial bound
root n holds trivially so he's just
saying you know if you want something
which
says that something non-trivial happens
then it happens at one fourth
okay yeah yeah yeah thanks james thank
you
so back to like the question i said
asked before i just want to
like add that even if you
have like a black box sampler
and you want to avoid like errors due to
like rounding errors like you know
computer
rounding errors it could be that this
framework is helpful
because right this is exactly what you
wanna if
if you just want to compute the
covariance matrix
best based on some black box sampler
yeah then it makes a lot of sense to run
exactly this algorithm to avoid
you know rounding issues yeah yeah i
i agree yeah one day i will probably
implement this if i am free
any final questions for you and said
before we take a break
okay so that's it let's thank the intent
again and we will reconvene
at 11 30 a.m pacific time which is in 40
minutes
for those of you who are not we're in
different time zones thank you
thanks